Not long ago, Cory was driving home with his girlfriend, Dominique, from his job with the Chicago Transit Authority. He's a painter for them. When somebody spray paints graffiti on a subway stop, he's the guy who paints over it. He's 26. She's 22. So they're driving home.
不久前，科里（Cory）和他的女友多米尼克（Dominique）下班开车回家。科里在芝加哥交通管理局工作，是一名油漆工。如果有人在地铁站喷涂涂鸦，他就是负责把涂鸦刷掉的那个人。他今年26岁，她22岁。他们当时正开车回家。
And a truck pulled on the side of me. And a guy was like gesturing. You know, I looked to the side and the guy was like gesturing. With my windows up, I didn't know what he was saying. So by this time, the light turned green and we both went forward. And I'm just looking like, like what?
一辆卡车开到了我旁边。有个家伙在打手势。你知道，我向旁边看去，那人一直在打手势。我的车窗是关着的，我不知道他在说什么。就在这时，绿灯亮了，我们都向前开了。我当时一脸困惑，心想怎么回事？
They wrote on the window. And from that point, things happened pretty quickly. They guy curses at him and throws a beer can, which actually comes through the window and lands inside spilling beer on Dominique. Cory throws one of those sample sized paint cans back at the guy. And then the other car, a gray SUV starts to follow Cory and Dominique. Cory tries to lose him making turns, driving through a parking lot. Here's Dominique.
他们在车窗上写字。从那一刻起，事情发生得很快。那家伙对他咒骂，扔出一个啤酒罐，罐子竟然穿过车窗落进车里，啤酒洒在多米尼克身上。科里把一个样品大小的油漆罐扔回去还击。接着，另一辆车，一辆灰色SUV开始尾随科里和多米尼克。科里试图通过转弯、穿过停车场来甩掉他们。听听多米尼克的讲述。
I'm looking in my side mirror. And I'm like, they're still behind us. I couldn't believe that they were still behind us after we'd went down a side street and come up through the back of the mall and we're going through the parking lot. And I just couldn't believe that they were still behind us at this point. I'm getting scared, real scared. I'm like, oh my god, Cory, they're still behind us. They're still behind us. And he's like, OK, just calm down, calm down.
我看着侧后视镜，心想，他们还在后面。我们穿过一条侧街，绕过商场后方，正穿过停车场，我真不敢相信他们竟然还在跟着我们。我开始害怕了，非常害怕。我说：“天哪，科里，他们还在后面。他们还在后面。”他说：“好了，冷静点，冷静点。”
135th Street, that's when we heard the gun shots. So then I just figured I'd go through the project area. Because I just figured whoever is shooting, they're not going go through the project area. Maybe they'll just turn off or whatever.
到了135街，我们听到了枪声。所以我决定开进公共住宅区。因为我想，不管是谁在开枪，他们肯定不会进到那种住宅区里。也许他们会转弯走掉之类的。
So when I turn, I hear some more gun shots. And that's when I hear the back window bust out. I can hear Dominique screaming, and it's like I can just see a flash of light. The bullet had came through the back window.
当我转弯时，又听到几声枪响。接着我听到后窗玻璃破碎的声音。我能听见多米尼克在尖叫，我就像看到了一道闪光。子弹穿过了后窗。
It seemed like a movie. It was like it was smoke. I could see people running. There was a guy on a motorcycle in front of me. He takes off. I could just see people in the headlights, and I just take off right behind them.
感觉就像电影一样。到处都是烟雾。我能看到人们在奔跑。我前面有一辆摩托车，那人加速逃走了。我只能在车灯前看到人们的身影，于是我紧跟在他们后面加速驶去。
This is probably as good a place as any to tell you who was chasing them. They were being pursued by five white off-duty police officers from Cook County Sheriff's Office who'd been drinking at a cocktail fundraiser for the sheriff, and then after that at a bar. They were not in uniform.
这里或许是告诉你们谁在追赶他们的好地方。追赶他们的是五名休班的库克县治安官办公室的白人警察，他们当时在治安官的一个募款鸡尾酒会上喝了酒，之后又去了一家酒吧。他们没有穿制服。
Lawyers for the officers declined our requests for interviews. But we do have a recording of them made the night of the shootings when they called 911 from their SUV on a cell phone.
警官们的律师拒绝了我们的采访请求。但我们有他们枪击当晚在SUV里用手机拨打911的录音。
(SUBJECT) 911 DISPATCHER Counter  emergency TC-14. How may I help you?
911调度中心，紧急服务，我是TC-14。请问有什么可以帮您？
Yeah, I've been on the phone [UNINTELLIGIBLE] with pursuit. I'm an off-duty police officer. Where is everybody at?
是的，我一直在电话里……在进行追捕。我是一名休班警察。大家都在哪儿？
This is officer Robert Jones telling two different 911 dispatchers that he's in pursuit of a vehicle and they should send backup.
这是罗伯特·琼斯（Robert Jones）警官在告诉两名不同的911调度员，他正在追捕一辆车，让他们派后援。
We are at 159th and Kedzie. We're at 159th and Kedzie, 159th and Kedzie.
我们在159街和凯齐（Kedzie）路口。我们在159街和凯齐路口，159街和凯齐路口。
What kind of car is it?
是什么车？
159th and Kedzie. We are following a gray Chevy Blazer, gray Chevy Blazer.
159街和凯齐。我们正在跟踪一辆灰色雪佛兰开拓者，灰色雪佛兰开拓者。
Actually, they're following a tan Ford Explorer. They're in a gray Chevy.
其实，他们跟踪的是一辆棕褐色的福特探险者。他们自己开的是一辆灰色雪佛兰。
We are northbound, northbound, northbound Kedzie from 159. Northbound Kedzie from 159.
我们正沿着凯齐路向北行驶，从159街出发向北。正沿着凯齐路向北，从159街出发。
OK, all right.
好的，明白了。
Northbound Kedzie 159. Northbound Kedzie from 159. We are approaching 159. [INTERPOSING VOICES].
凯齐路向北，159街。凯齐路向北，从159街出发。我们正在接近159街。（交叉对话）
OK, sir, sir, sir.
好的，先生，先生，先生。
At no point did we know that they were police officers. They could've been anyone.
我们自始至终都不知道他们是警察。他们可能是任何人。
I didn't know what they were after or whatever. It is not like I would have just pulled over and say, OK, why are you following me? In this day and age, why would you pull over? Everything is going on in the world and I'm going to pull over and see why you're following me?
我不知道他们究竟想干什么。我不可能仅仅因为有人跟着，就靠边停车问他们：“嘿，你们为什么要跟着我？”在这个年代，为什么要靠边停车？世界上正发生着各种事，我要停下车去问他们为什么要跟踪我？
Although there were five officers in the car following him, on the 911 tape, Officer Jones gets the number wrong a couple times saying there were six officers or seven.
尽管当时有五名警官在那辆跟随的车里，但在911录音中，琼斯警官几次报错了人数，说是六个或七个。
Their side of it is this. They say they were chasing a reckless driver, and that they only started shooting after somebody shot at them. No gun was found in Cory Simmons' car. He denies having a gun.
他们的说法是这样的：他们声称自己在追捕一名鲁莽驾驶的司机，而且只是在有人向他们开枪后才开始回击的。科里·西蒙斯（Cory Simmons）的车里并没有搜出枪支。他否认自己持有枪支。
But listening on the 911 tape, it does seem possible that the officers thought they heard shots, even if none had been fired.
但听着911录音，警察们似乎真的以为听到了枪声，尽管当时根本没开过枪。
Yeah. We have seven off-duty police officers in our car. There is one-- oh! Shots fired, shots fired, shots fired. Shots fired. There are shots fired.
好的。我们车里有七名休班警察。这儿有一个——噢！有枪声，有枪声，有枪声。有枪声。真的有枪声。
Where are you at, sir?
您在哪儿，先生？
Also on the tape, you hear the officers in the background laughing and saying boom, boom, boom. And then there's this when they point to an alley in pursuit.
在录音里，你还能听到背景里有警察在笑，还喊着“砰，砰，砰”。接着就是他们指示追击方向时的一幕。
Go around and kill the lights. Kill the lights. They're going to try to block us out of here. [BLEEP]. No, [BLEEP] them. Drive right around. Not them the [BLEEP] off the road. He might have turned right there.
绕过去，把车灯关了。关掉车灯。他们想把我们堵在这里。（脏话）不，（脏话）管他们去死。直接绕过去。把他们挤出路面。他可能在那儿右转了。
Some time passes.
过了一段时间。
Kill them. Kill them.
干掉他们。干掉他们。
Hello?
喂？
We have [BLEEP] guns.
我们有（脏话）枪。
The chase ended when Cory and Dominique finally spotted a police station and ran inside saying somebody was chasing them trying to kill them. When the officers were brought in, they first denied firing their guns. But of course there were bullet holes in Cory's car. So the police were asked to turn over their guns for ballistic tests to see if they'd been fired. Dominique and Cory said that at first, they refused.
追捕在科里和多米尼克最终发现一个警察局并跑进去求救时结束了，他们说有人在追杀他们。当那些警察被带进来时，他们起初否认开过枪。但显然，科里的车上有弹孔。于是警方被要求上交枪支进行弹道测试，看是否开过火。多米尼克和科里说，起初，他们拒绝上交。
When the police came to trial on charges of attempted murder, aggravated discharge of a firearm, official misconduct, and obstruction of justice, the judge said that they had only been guilty of bad judgment, that there wasn't enough evidence to convict them on any of the charges. Even though the five officers were drinking and using their guns, and firing a gun from a moving vehicle, both of those things in violation of department rules, they weren't even convicted of official misconduct.
当这些警察因谋杀未遂、严重非法开枪、公职人员行为不检和妨碍司法公正受到审判时，法官说他们只是判断失误，没有足够的证据将他们定罪。尽管这五名警察在饮酒后动用了枪支，并且在行驶的车辆中开火——这两点都违反了部门规定，但他们甚至没有被判公职人员行为不检罪。
The judge in your case said, if I could sentence these officers to wear red noses for the bozos they are, I would do that. But I can't do that. What did you think of that?
法官在判决中说，如果能判这些警察戴上红鼻子，因为他们就是一群小丑，我会这么做的。但我不能那样做。对此你怎么看？
It was a stupid thing to say for a judge. I mean, he's supposed to be intelligent, right? It was a stupid thing to say.
这对法官来说是个愚蠢的说法。我的意思是，他应该是个聪明人，对吧？那是句愚蠢的话。
A very stupid thing to say.
非常愚蠢的话。
They guy is up for attempted murder and you call him a bozo? A bozo is a clown, he play with kids. This is a grown man shooting at people trying to kill them.
这家伙面临谋杀未遂指控，而你却称他为小丑？小丑是滑稽演员，那是演给孩子们看的。这是一个成年男人在向人开枪并企图杀人。
Here I do everything right that they say you're supposed to do, and I'm getting shot at like I'm some type of criminal or something like that. I just think that they were wrong. I can't say it's all cops. I just think that they were wrong. And I think race did have something to do with it. I think if I was white that we wouldn't be sitting here. I don't think that it would have happened if I was white, that they would have been shooting at me or saying that they thought I maybe I was dirty or had a warrant or a gun on me and that's why I didn't want to pull over.
我按他们要求的一切正确行事，结果却像个罪犯一样被枪击。我只是认为他们错了。我不能说所有警察都这样，我只是觉得他们当时错了。我觉得种族因素在其中起了作用。如果我是白人，我们现在就不会坐在这里了。我不认为如果我是白人会发生这种事，他们会对我开枪，或者声称怀疑我是坏人、身上有通缉令或枪支，所以才不肯停车。
Cory says he's heard of police brutality, of course, but he never thought something like this could happen to him driving home from work one night. And one of the interesting things about this story is what a non-story it is. Here in Chicago where the whole thing happened, it's made of paper a few times. But there is no big public uproar. It's not the subject of speeches. You don't see politicians on TV backpedaling and prevaricating. It has not made national news at all as far as we can tell. Five cops go drinking and shoot at a middle class black couple, whatever.
科里说他当然听说过警察暴力，但他从未想过这种事会发生在他某天晚上下班回家的路上。这个故事最有趣的一点是，它竟然算不上一个新闻。在事情发生的芝加哥，它只在报纸上提过几次。但没有引发巨大的公众骚动。它不是演讲的主题。你看不到政客们在电视上为此辩解。据我们所知，它根本没上过全国新闻。五名警察去喝酒，然后向一对中产阶级的黑人夫妇开枪，就这样而已。
What always kind of sticks out in my mind when we have these kinds of cases is that there's not the same level of outrage, not only for the public, but for the victims themselves.
每当我们遇到这类案件时，我心中总是会浮现出一个疑问，那就是为什么公众，甚至受害者本身，没有表现出同样的愤怒。
Tiffany Ferguson is one of the lawyers who's going to represent Cory Ferguson and Dominique Mapp in a civil suit against the police.
蒂芙尼·弗格森（Tiffany Ferguson）是将代表科里·弗格森和多米尼克·马普对警方提起民事诉讼的律师之一。
We have all sorts of clients in the office, of course. And when people contact our office, and it's a person who is white who has been victimized, their level of outrage, I can't describe to you. But they feel so violated. How could this have happened to me? I'm doing what I'm supposed to be doing. I'm following the law. I haven't done anything wrong. And we're talking about something as minor as getting a traffic ticket that they shouldn't have gotten. And they're ready to sue everybody.
我们办公室代理各种各样的客户，当然。当联系我们的受害者是白人时，他们的愤怒程度我无法描述。他们感觉受到了深深的侵犯。他们会说：“这种事怎么会发生在我身上？我做了我该做的事。我遵守了法律。我什么错事都没做。”我们谈论的有时仅仅是像不该得到的交通罚单那样的小事，但他们却准备起诉所有人。
When it happens to someone black, and this is my opinion, often times the person feels like, this is terrible. But this is my life. This is kind of the cards I've been dealt. And so that level of outrage is almost like you have to remind the victim that this is insane that you have to deal with this. This is completely violative of your rights.
而当这种事发生在黑人身上时——这是我的看法——那个人通常会觉得：“这太糟糕了。但这就是我的生活。这就是我抽到的牌。”所以那种愤怒程度通常需要你提醒受害者：“你必须处理这种事本身就是疯狂的。这完全侵犯了你的权利。”
WBEZ Chicago, the Public Radio International. It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Today on our program, High Speed Chase. We bring you not one, no, no, but two, two stories high speed car chases and the law. Actually I guess it's kind of a special law and order edition of our program. You'll hear the crime, and you'll hear how the justice system dealt with the crime. Yes, in the criminal justice system, the people are represented by two separate and equally important groups, the police to investigate crimes, and public radio reporters who interview them after the fact. These are their stories. Stay with us.
这里是芝加哥WBEZ，隶属国际公共广播电台。这是《此美国生活》（This American Life）。我是艾拉·格拉斯（Ira Glass）。今天我们节目的主题是《高速追捕》。我们带来的不是一个，而是两个关于高速汽车追逐与法律的故事。实际上，这大概算是我们节目的特别“法律与秩序”版。你将听到犯罪，并听到司法系统如何处理这些犯罪。是的，在刑事司法系统中，人们由两个独立且同样重要的群体代表：调查犯罪的警察，以及事后采访他们的公共广播记者。这就是他们的故事。请继续收听。
Let's call this Act 2, Cowboys and Indians. In this act, another high speed chase, though the participants in this particular case began running after each other across the plains and deserts of this country long before the invention of automobiles. I'm talking about Native Americans and white people. In South Dakota, after all of these years, the two groups are still not getting along. Things are so bad that some people compare race relations in the state to Mississippi in 1960.
我们称这一章为“牛仔与印第安人”。在这一章里，会有另一场高速追捕，尽管在这个特定案例中，双方早在汽车发明之前，就已经在这片土地的平原和沙漠上互相追逐了。我说的是美洲原住民和白人。在南达科他州，这么多年过去了，这两个群体依然无法相处。情况极其糟糕，有些人甚至把该州的种族关系比作1960年的密西西比州。
And last fall after a high school girls basketball game, an incident between a group of Native American girls and a group of white boys escalated to the points where shots were fired from a speeding car. What happened in the months that followed did not seem fair to either side. Susan Burton tells the story.
去年秋天，在一场高中女子篮球赛后，一群原住民女孩和一群白人男孩之间发生了一起冲突，升级到了一辆行驶中的汽车向人开枪的地步。随后的几个月里发生的事情，对双方而言似乎都不公平。苏珊·伯顿（Susan Burton）来讲述这个故事。
Basketball is big just about everywhere in South Dakota. It's big and small towns, big on Indian reservations, and there are plenty of parents from both places who never miss a game. On November 1, Lucille Weasel Bear drove five hours from the Pine Ridge Indian Reservation to a small town called Miller to see her daughter Arlene play in the district finals.
篮球在南达科他州几乎到处都很重要。在小城镇很重要，在印第安保留地也很重要，而且两边都有很多从不错过比赛的家长。11月1日，露西尔·威瑟尔·贝尔（Lucille Weasel Bear）从松岭印第安保留地开车五个小时来到一个叫米勒（Miller）的小镇，观看女儿阿琳（Arlene）参加地区决赛。
Miller seemed like a typical small town, railroad tracks at one end, a dairy queen at the other. Lucille surveyed the one along main street, parked outside the armory, and went straight in.
米勒看起来像个典型的小镇，一头是铁轨，另一头是乳品皇后冰淇淋店。露西尔环顾了主街，把车停在体育馆外，径直走了进去。
The first thing I look for is a good spot up in the bleachers because I do a lot of videotaping. And then so I found me one. And then there were some Indian women that sat by me. But when they sat down, this lady said, did they tell you where to sit when you came in the gym? And the other said, no. And she said, well when I came in, they told me Indians on that side and white people on that side. And I heard that, and I was like, gee, who would say that? They could say Chieftains on that side and Spartans or whatever they call them on that side. But Indians on this side and whatever.
我首先寻找的是看台上一个好的位置，因为我经常拍摄录像。然后我找到了一个。我旁边坐着一些印第安妇女。但她们坐下时，这位女士问：“你们进来时有人告诉你们坐哪儿吗？”另一个人说没有。她说：“哦，我进来的时候，他们告诉我印第安人坐那边，白人坐那边。”听到这话，我心想，天哪，谁会这么说？他们可以叫“酋长队”坐那边，“斯巴达人队”或者别的什么名字坐那边。但是，“印第安人坐这边”什么的……
Tonight the Crow Creek Chieftains were playing the Wessington Springs Spartans. And it was a big game. The winner would have a shot at making state. The loser's season would be over. The trouble began as the Crow Creek players entered the gym. Jessica Squirrel Coat is the team's MVP, the kind of girl who people talk about as if she's famous, an honor student, strikingly pretty with long black hair to her waste.
今晚，克劳溪（Crow Creek）的“酋长队”对阵威辛顿温泉（Wessington Springs）的“斯巴达人队”。这是一场重要比赛。赢家将有机会进入州赛。输家的赛季就结束了。麻烦始于克劳溪的队员走进体育馆时。杰西卡·松鼠外套（Jessica Squirrel Coat）是该队的MVP，人们谈论她就像她很有名一样，她是荣誉学生，有着惊人的美貌和垂到腰际的长黑发。
And then as we were running out, we came on our side, we came under their hoop right by the Wessington Springs fans' area. And as soon as we went by their area, we heard those war whooping. I looked down. I was like, right now it's dirty in the beginning of the game. How you see it on cartoons, that's how you hear it.
当我们跑出去时，我们来到自己的半场，正好经过对方篮下，就在斯巴达人队球迷区旁边。我们一经过那个区域，就听到了那种模仿印第安人的叫喊声。我往下看去，心想：比赛刚开始就这么卑劣。就像在动画片里看到的那样，听起来就是那样。
From the stands, Lucille heard the war whoops too. This happens every so often at basketball games, and it's disturbing.
从看台上，露西尔也听到了这种叫喊。这种事在篮球比赛中时有发生，而且令人不安。
I noticed way on the left side across the gym floor, a group of non-Indians. There were a group of white kids. And I noticed when our girls came running in how they were war whooping and hollering and dancing right there, right where they were standing at their bleacher turning around. I see that, but I think that well, gee, if they want to live that way, that's them.
我注意到在球场另一端的左侧，坐着一群非原住民。那是一群白人小孩。我注意到当我们的女孩跑进来时，他们在那儿又喊又叫，模仿印第安战号，就在看台边又跳又叫。我看到了，但我心想，好吧，如果他们想那样生活，那是他们的事。
[CHEERLEADERS CHEERING]
（啦啦队欢呼声）
On the video of the game, you see the silver flash of pom poms, you see Wessington Springs' best player racing down the court, her blond ponytail flopping behind her. You see Jessica shooting three-pointers. You can't hear any racial remarks. But she and the other Crow Creek players insist they were said.
在比赛录像中，你能看到银色闪烁的啦啦队彩球，看到斯巴达人队最好的球员在球场上飞奔，金色的马尾辫在身后甩动。你看到杰西卡投三分球。你听不到任何种族主义言论。但她和其他克劳溪队员坚称那些话确实被说了。
Near the end of the third quarter, Jessica and the girl with the blond ponytail collided. Together they stumbled into the wall. The other girl fell to the floor and lay very still. It looked like she hit hard and was hurt. A foul was called. The mood in the gym got worse. There was booing.
第三节快结束时，杰西卡和那个扎马尾辫的女孩撞在了一起。她们一起跌向墙壁。另一个女孩摔在地上，一动不动地躺着。看起来她摔得很重，受伤了。裁判吹了犯规。体育馆里的气氛变得更糟了。观众开始嘘声。
The blond girl got up. Jessica stepped away from the wall and went to line up next to Lucille's daughter whose nickname is Chub. As Chub and Jessica passed the Wessington Springs fans, Jessica heard somebody yell something at her.
金发女孩站了起来。杰西卡离开墙边，排在露西尔女儿（绰号“胖妞”）旁边。当胖妞和杰西卡经过斯巴达人的球迷时，杰西卡听到有人对她喊了什么。
She's dirty. She's a dirty Indian. She's very dirty. And I just looked and Chubs and she looked at me. She smiled at me. She's like, don't pay attention. Just don't pay attention. I was like, I know, I'm not even trying.
“她很脏。她是个肮脏的印第安人。她非常脏。”我看向胖妞，她看着我。她对我笑了笑，好像在说：“别理会。千万别理会。”我说：“我知道，我根本没打算理会。”
Then that girl went to the three-throw line.
接着那个女孩走上了罚球线。
This is Jessica's mother, Jenny.
这是杰西卡的母亲，珍妮（Jenny）。
And she was bent over bouncing the ball, getting ready to do her free throw. And Jessica went up to her. And I think she said something like, are you OK? Because it seemed to settle the atmosphere down. And Jessica pulled back behind the players that were all lines up for the free throw line.
她弯下腰运球，准备罚球。杰西卡走近她。我想她说了一句类似“你还好吗？”的话，因为那似乎平复了一下气氛。杰西卡退到了所有排队等罚球的队员身后。
[CHEERLEADERS CHEERING]
（啦啦队欢呼声）
[UNINTELLIGIBLE] Crow Creek has possession and it was like 14 seconds, I don't know. They gave the ball to Jessie. She attempted the shot to go up. And just like that they grabbed it out of her hands. Within seven seconds the girl took it down the court and made a shot at the buzzer. Wessington Springs won.
克劳溪队拥有球权，大概还有14秒，我不知道。他们把球传给杰西。她试图投篮。就在这时，她们从她手中把球抢走了。七秒之内，那个女孩带球到底线并在哨响时进球。威辛顿温泉队赢了。
[CROWD CHEERING]
（人群欢呼声）
Jessie collapsed to the floor and she was crying. Her arms folded underneath her face. She was just sobbing. And I couldn't get her off the floor. I halfway got down and I was holding her.
杰西瘫倒在地上，她哭了。她的双臂叠在脸下。她只是在抽泣。我没法让她从地上起来。我半蹲下来抱住她。
Wessington Springs had won the district finals by two points. The Crow Creek girls collapsed exactly where they were when the buzzer sounded, mid-court under the net.
威辛顿温泉队以两分之差赢得了地区决赛。克劳溪的女孩们在终场哨响时就倒在了原地，球场中央篮架下方。
Outside the gym, the night was starry and cool. Parents got into their cars and followed the Crow Creek bus up to the Dairy Queen for dinner. There were 30 or so Native Americans inside. It smells like Indians, a girl from Crow Creek heard someone remark. Jessica ordered a double cheeseburger and strawberry banana smoothie. The Crow Creek players say they kept being served hamburgers that only had bottom buns. They say that when they complained, they were told, are you sure you're not just eating the top bun and bringing it back?
体育馆外，夜空星光闪烁，空气凉爽。家长们坐进车里，跟随克劳溪队的校车去乳品皇后吃晚饭。里面有大约30名原住民。一个克劳溪的女孩听到有人评论说：“闻起来像印第安人。”杰西卡点了一个双层芝士汉堡和草莓香蕉冰沙。克劳溪队员们说她们收到的汉堡只有底下的面包。她们说当她们投诉时，店员回答道：“你们确定不是自己吃掉了上面的面包，然后拿回来抱怨吗？”
Crow Creek is a boarding school. And Jessica and Arlene had permission to ride back to campus in their friends pickup. There were six girls in the car. They cracked a couple windows to get some air, smoke a cigarette. They drove south on the main street. And a few blocks later they came to a vacant lot. It seemed like a hangout spot. There were cars there, eight or so boys standing outside them.
克劳溪是一所寄宿学校。杰西卡和阿琳获准乘坐朋友的皮卡车回学校。车里有六个女孩。她们摇下几扇车窗透透气，抽了支烟。她们沿着主街向南行驶。几个街区后，她们来到一片空地。那似乎是个聚集点。那儿停着几辆车，大约八个男孩站在外面。
At this point, accounts differ. The boys say they said nothing. The girls say they could see the boys flipping them off under the streetlights. They say they heard them swearing at them. One girl said she heard a racial epithet. Jessica tells the rest of the story with her uncle, Jake Thompson, the vice-chairman of the Sisseton-Wahpeton Sioux Tribe, who later called for a federal civil rights investigation into the events surrounding this night.
此时，双方的说法不一。男孩们说他们什么也没说。女孩们说她们能看到男孩们在路灯下向她们竖中指。她们说听到了他们的咒骂。一个女孩说她听到了种族侮辱词汇。杰西卡和她的叔叔杰克·汤普森（Jake Thompson）讲述了后续的故事，杰克是西塞顿-瓦佩顿苏族部落的副主席，他后来要求对当晚发生的事件进行联邦民权调查。
They looked at each other. Did you hear this? Did you hear what I heard? They left and a decision was made to go around the block.
她们面面相觑。“你们听到了吗？你们听到了我听到的吗？”她们离开了，并决定绕街区转一圈。
We were like, just go back. See what they said. Make sure we heard what we hear.
我们当时想，回去看看。看看他们说了什么。确认我们听到的是真的。
So they took a right, went down the block, and came back in front of the same spot to see if this is what they had heard. And they heard it again.
于是她们右转，沿着街区转了一圈，又回到那个地点前方，看是不是真的听到了那些话。她们又听到了。
Jessica sat in the back seat holding her smoothie. She says she heard the boys swear at them again. In reaction, she passed the smoothie to the front of the car.
杰西卡坐在后座上拿着她的冰沙。她说她听到男孩们再次咒骂她们。出于反应，她把冰沙递到了前座。
Here, throw this at them. I was like, yeah, yes. Throw it at them. Everyone was agreeing with it. So we just kind of went by slowly, she rolled down her window. And then she threw it out. It just went all over.
“在这儿，扔向他们。”我当时想，“对，就是这样。扔向他们。”每个人都同意。所以我们慢慢开过去，她摇下车窗。然后把冰沙扔了出去。到处都是。
The smoothie hit a white car. Two of the boys jumped inside of it and peeled out of the lot. The girls sped down the main street bouncing over the railroad tracks on their way out of town. Now there were two cars from the parking lot chasing them. At times, they were going almost 90 miles an hour.
冰沙击中了一辆白车。两个男孩跳进车里，从空地飞驰而出。女孩们在主街上加速行驶，跳过铁轨驶出镇子。现在，那家空地的两辆车开始追赶她们。有时速度几乎达到每小时90英里。
Then the white car swerved out alongside the girls and one of the boys thrust a shotgun out of the passenger window. They've got a gun, the girls screamed. Go back to town. Go back to Dairy Queen.
接着那辆白车猛地别到女孩们的车旁边，其中一个男孩从副驾驶车窗伸出一把散弹枪。“他们有枪，”女孩们尖叫道。“回镇子去。回乳品皇后去。”
And what happens next is unbelievable. You just don't hear of these things, even in South Dakota after a basketball game. There was four shotgun blasts shot from the car.
接下来发生的事情简直难以置信。你根本没听说过这种事，即使是在篮球赛后的南达科他州。车里响起了四声散弹枪响。
That's when Chubs said, get down, get down. And that's when we had that back window cracked in. We heard four shots. They sound like old fire crackers.
那是胖妞说：“蹲下，快蹲下。”就在那时，我们的后窗破碎了。我们听到了四声枪响。听起来就像旧式的鞭炮声。
The girls were on the floor. They heard the shots but nothing hit the car. Go, go, they screamed to the driver. She raced through Miller running lights. Finally she made it to Dairy Queen. The Crow Creek Chieftains' bus was still there. The parents were still inside.
女孩们趴在车底。她们听到了枪声，但没打中车身。司机一路闯红灯，疯狂加速。最终她们赶到了乳品皇后。克劳溪的校车还在那儿。家长们还在里面。
They are beside themselves. They pull up in a parking lot. And that car pulled up. The one who had a shotgun and did the firing pulled up next to them. Five of them exit out and they make it inside scared for their lives.
她们惊魂未定。她们驶入停车场。那辆车跟了上来。那辆持有散弹枪并开火的车，停在了她们旁边。车上的五个人冲下车，女孩们吓得赶紧跑进店里保命。
This left one girl still stuck in the car.
还有一个女孩被困在车里。
She couldn't get her seat belt unfastened. The two men-- the two boys, rather-- inside the car had the shotgun on their laps. She sees the barrel of the shotgun. It's raised a little bit. And they tell her, go home, leave, you f-ing Indian, you f-ing prairie nigger.
她没法解开安全带。车里的两个男的——或者说两个男孩，把散弹枪放在大腿上。她看到了散弹枪的枪管。它稍微抬了起来。他们对她说：“滚回家，快滚，你这该死的印第安人，该死的草原黑鬼。”
She gets her seat belt unfastened, makes it to the glass doors of the Dairy Queen. And she goes to the bathroom on herself she was so scared.
她终于解开了安全带，跑向乳品皇后的玻璃门。她吓得尿了裤子。
I thought I was in shock. I didn't know what to think. The only thought I had was like, oh my god, they have a gun. They went to that extreme to bring a gun into it. [INAUDIBLE PHRASE]. I was just so shocked.
我以为自己处于休克状态。我不知道该想什么。我脑子里唯一的念头就是：天哪，他们竟然有枪。他们竟然极端到把枪都带上了。（听不清短语）。我当时太震惊了。
The two boys deny making any racial remarks. The girl who was stuck in her seat belt went to the restroom and locked herself in. Her aunt and her cousin shut themselves in there with her. Most everyone else watched the windows waiting for the police to arrive.
两个男孩否认发表过任何种族言论。那个被困在安全带里的女孩跑进洗手间把自己锁在里面。她的阿姨和堂妹也躲了进去。其他人大多守在窗边等待警察到来。
What the people inside did not know is that these boys had went straight to their home, left the shotgun there, then went to the police station and told them that these girls threw some ice cream at their car. So they should look into this.
店里的人并不知道的是，这些男孩直接回了家，把散弹枪留在那儿，然后去了警察局，告诉警察这些女孩往他们车上扔了冰淇淋。所以他们应该调查这件事。
Ten minutes after the boys made their vandalism report, the police department got a call from Dairy Queen about the shooting. An officer arrived. And as he began to talk to the girls, the white car returned to the parking lot. People pointed and shouted, do something. Stop those boys. They're the ones that did this.
男孩们报案 vandalized（破坏财物）十分钟后，警察局接到了乳品皇后关于枪击事件的报警电话。一名警官赶到现场。正当他开始与女孩们交谈时，那辆白车回到了停车场。人们指着车大喊：“做点什么。拦住那些男孩。就是他们干的。”
The police officer doesn't know what to think. He turns around, tells the car to stay right there. Don't move. The car leaves.
警官不知道该怎么办。他转过身，示意那辆车呆在那儿。别动。那辆车开走了。
The officer set out after the boys. People hovered in the entryway making telephone calls. The news was starting to spread. Some kids back at Crow Creek heard the shooting report on their police scanners. Two women who worked at Dairy Queen took the girls to the police department. They wrote brief statements.
警官追赶男孩们去了。人们聚在门口打电话。消息开始传开。克劳溪的一些孩子在警用扫描仪上听到了枪击报告。乳品皇后的两名女员工把女孩们带到了警察局。她们写了简短的陈述。
Later, much was made of the fact that they didn't mention the racial slurs in their statements. They only mention the shooting. But the main reason for the omission was that their coach was in a hurry to get them home and the girls weren't instructed on exactly what needed to be in their accounts. The boys were found and questioned, and then the night was over. The girls drove back to school in their pickup and the boys went home with their parents. They had not been arrested. Nobody had been injured. The case would be under investigation.
后来，人们抓着她们陈述中没提种族歧视用语这点大做文章。她们只提到了枪击事件。但遗漏的主要原因是教练急着带她们回家，而女孩们没被教导陈述里到底需要写什么。男孩们被找到并审问，那个夜晚就结束了。女孩们坐皮卡车回了学校，男孩们随父母回了家。他们没有被逮捕。没有人受伤。案件被列入调查。
The people in Miller felt that something bad had happened in their community that night, something that never should have happened. But for them, it was an isolated incident. But on the reservation, from that very first night when the police decided not to arrest the boys, the shooting was seen as symbolic of the way justice operates in South Dakota. The system doesn't take crimes against Indians seriously, they say, and punishes them more harshly than it does whites.
米勒的居民觉得那晚社区里发生了一件坏事，一件本不该发生的事。但对他们来说，这只是个孤立事件。但在保留地上，从警察决定不逮捕男孩的那晚起，枪击案就被视为南达科他州司法运作方式的象征。他们说，体制不把针对印第安人的犯罪当回事，且对他们的惩罚比对白人更严厉。
1,500 people live in Miller. On the day I visit, a high wind screams down the main street lifting hundreds of soda cans out of a collection bin.
米勒有1500名居民。我造访的那天，强风在主街呼啸，从收集箱里卷起数百个苏打水罐。
Our case load sort of runs the gamut.
我们的案件类型包罗万象。
Jim Jones is the Hand County State's Attorney. He was in charge of prosecuting the Crow Creek case.
吉姆·琼斯（Jim Jones）是汉德县（Hand County）的州检察官。他负责起诉克劳溪案件。
We have our DWIs, our underaged consumptions, our burglaries, lots of traffic offenses. The last time we had a shot fired, to my knowledge, in Miller on one of our public streets was probably four or five years ago. A couple guys got in a tangle. I guess it was on East 1st Street. But that's the last time that I can think of that anybody fired a shot in anger on one of our city streets. This is highly unusual.
我们有酒驾、未成年饮酒、盗窃，还有大量的交通违章。据我所知，上一次在米勒的公共街道上发生枪击案，大概是四五年前了。几个家伙打架纠缠在一起。我猜是在东一街。但那是我想到的最后一次有人在城市街道上愤怒开火的事件。这太反常了。
Jim Jones is meticulous and focused. He smokes long cigarettes called Liggetts and exhales in tidy rings. He's 48 years old and has lived his entire life in Hand County. He started working on the Crow Creek case the morning after the shooting. He had the handwritten statements the girls had given to the police. He had the ones from the Miller boys. No one had said a thing about racial remarks.
吉姆·琼斯一丝不苟，非常专注。他抽着一种叫Liggetts的长香烟，呼出整齐的烟圈。他48岁，一生都住在汉德县。枪击事件发生后的第二天早上，他就开始着手处理克劳溪案件。他手里有女孩们给警察的亲笔陈述，也有米勒男孩们的陈述。没人提到过任何种族歧视言论。
I think it was the next day, or perhaps two days after November 1. A television station came to town and asked me whether or not our office viewed the events as having been racially motivated. And I said, well based upon what I've got in front of me here, I don't see it as racial in nature.
我想是11月1日之后的第二天或第三天。一家电视台来镇上问我，我们的办公室是否认为该事件是出于种族动机。我说：“好吧，根据我面前掌握的情况，我没看出它是种族性的。”
Racism isn't something people in Hand County deal with much, because there's basically just one race here. The Chieftain basketball team drove in from the county next door.
种族主义不是汉德县的人们常面对的问题，因为这里基本只有一种族裔。克劳溪篮球队是从隔壁县开车来的。
We are, oddly enough, according to the recent census statistics, one of the ten most racially unmixed populations in the nation. The ten most Caucasian counties in the nation include Hand County. And so race relations have not been a problem in this community, at least in 18 years I've been State's Attorney.
根据最近的人口普查统计，奇怪的是，我们是全国种族混杂度最低的十个地区之一。全国最白人的十个县里就包括汉德县。所以种族关系在这个社区不是个问题，至少在我担任州检察官的18年里是这样。
The South Dakota press quickly picked up news of the incident. Some stories implied that people in Miller weren't taking the crime as seriously as they should.
南达科他州的媒体很快就报道了这起事件。一些报道暗示米勒的人们并没有像应该的那样认真对待这起犯罪。
All of the publicity was extremely negative. The Miller police department, my office, the State's Attorney's Office, the court system, most of those persons or entities that I just mentioned were painted with a broad brush as racist, prejudiced, incompetent, unwilling to see reality. We were all excoriated.
所有的报道都极其负面。米勒警察局、我的办公室、州检察官办公室、法院系统，我刚才提到的那些人或机构大多被一概而论地贴上了种族主义者、有偏见、无能、不愿面对现实的标签。我们都被抨击了。
Jim Jones has a folder of all the articles in front of us on his desk. He starts to flip through them and try to find parts to read. He gets so frustrated that he shuts the folder. He thinks the stories make him look like he didn't know how to handle this case, that he didn't care about getting justice for the Native American girls. He says the press reports made things especially awkward for him with the Crow Creek girls and their families. It's hard enough to cross from one world to another in South Dakota.
吉姆·琼斯的办公桌上有一个文件夹，里面装着所有的报道文章。他开始翻找，试图找段落读给我听。他感到非常沮丧，以至于把文件夹关上了。他认为这些报道让他看起来像是个不会处理案件的人，不在乎为那些原住民女孩伸张正义。他说媒体报道让他在处理克劳溪女孩及其家人的事情时显得格外尴尬。在南达科他州，从一个世界走到另一个世界已经够难了。
Some Indians say that living conditions on the reservations get worse as you drive west in South Dakota. And Pine Ridge is the westernmost reservation in the state. But it's radio station, KINI FM, makes Pine Ridge seem a lot less bleak. It broadcast everything from country songs to pow wow music to the names of the children who are graduating from the Little Womb School's kindergarten class.
一些印第安人说，在南达科他州越往西走，保留地上的生活条件就越差。松岭是该州最西端的保留地。但它的电台，KINI FM，让松岭听起来没那么凄凉。它播放从乡村歌曲到“波瓦”（pow wow）音乐，再到Little Womb学校幼儿园毕业班孩子的名字。
Congratulations to Tristan Apple, Tyler Hairy Bird, Asa Old Horse, Autumn Little White Man, Alan Little White Man, Brandon Little White Man, Tammy Wounded Head, and Phil Zinegot Junior. This message is brought to you by the Little Womb School and KINI FM Radio, the voice of the Lakota nation.
祝贺崔斯坦·苹果（Tristan Apple）、泰勒·多毛鸟（Tyler Hairy Bird）、阿萨·老马（Asa Old Horse）、秋·小白人（Autumn Little White Man）、艾伦·小白人（Alan Little White Man）、布兰登·小白人（Brandon Little White Man）、塔米·受伤头（Tammy Wounded Head）和菲尔·齐内戈特（Phil Zinegot Junior）。此消息由Little Womb学校和KINI FM电台提供，这是拉科塔民族之声。
[MUSIC PLAYING]
（音乐播放）
Kind of small. These houses are kind of small. But they work.
有点小。这些房子有点小。但它们能用。
Arlene Weasel Bear not only plays power forward on the Crow Creek basketball team, she's an MVP in golf and wrestles well enough to have gone with the team to Tokyo. She has five sisters, and in the living room, a large collection of awards and photographs adorns the walls. A basketball magic markered with her nickname, Chub, sits on top of the TV.
阿琳·威瑟尔·贝尔不仅是克劳溪篮球队的大前锋，她还是高尔夫球项目的MVP，摔跤水平也高到足以随队去东京。她有五个姐妹，起居室的墙上装饰着大量的奖项和照片。一个写着她绰号“胖妞”的篮球放在电视机顶上。
Being in this room is like standing inside a scrapbook. There are Head Start graduation photos and prom pictures. Then, amidst all the medals, Arlene's mom, Lucille, points out a newspaper clipping.
置身这个房间就像站在一本剪贴簿里。这里有启蒙班的毕业照和舞会照片。然后，在众多的奖牌中间，阿琳的妈妈露西尔指着一张剪报。
OK, and this was in the Lakota Journal, like a Native American newspaper. But this is really something. The parents of the Crow Creek Tribal School girls basketball players are wondering if their children need to wear bulletproof vests when venturing off the reservation for sports.
好的，这是在《拉科塔日报》上，就像是一份美洲原住民报纸。但这真的……家长们都在想，他们的孩子在离开保留地参加体育比赛时，是否需要穿上防弹背心。
This was the second time something traumatic happened to Arlene when she left the reservation for a basketball game. The first time was during a tournament several years ago when a white woman said that Arlene was a boy and her team should be disqualified. Someone took Arlene and a couple of her teammates into a stall in the bathroom and checked. Arlene's mother and some other parents took legal action. But the case was thrown out of court.
这是阿琳第二次在离开保留地参加篮球比赛时发生创伤性事件。第一次是几年前在一次锦标赛期间，一名白人妇女说阿琳是个男孩，她的球队应该被取消参赛资格。有人把阿琳和她的几个队友带进洗手间的隔间里检查。阿琳的母亲和其他家长采取了法律行动。但案件被法院驳回了。
This year, after the incident in Miller, Arlene and the other girls all had a tough time recovering. The girl who couldn't unbuckle her seat belt in the Dairy Queen parking lot is still so upset that she doesn't want to talk to me on tape. Jessica's mother says that Jessica's personality changed. Jessica was the Crow Creek homecoming queen. She has so many friends that people say she's doing one of seven rights of the Sioux Nation, making relatives. But after Miller, she'd stay in her dorm room, just lie on her bed and listen to her pow wow CDs. She'd pray with her medicine bundle, which she made a couple years ago after she felt a sharp pain in her leg like someone was using bad medicine on her when she came down from making a layup during a basketball game.
今年，米勒事件后，阿琳和其他女孩都经历了艰难的恢复期。那个在乳品皇后停车场解不开安全带的女孩至今仍非常难过，不想在录音里跟我说话。杰西卡的母亲说杰西卡的性格变了。杰西卡曾是克劳溪的返校节女王。她朋友多到人们说她正在实现苏族民族七大权利之一——广结善缘。但在米勒事件后，她总是呆在宿舍房间里，躺在床上听她的波瓦音乐CD。她会用她的药袋祈祷，那是她几年前做的，当时她在篮球赛中上篮落地时感觉到腿部一阵剧痛，仿佛有人在对她使用邪术。
After the basketball game in Miller, Arlene went back to the dorms at Crow Creek. But she started calling home more than usual. A couple weeks later, she came for a visit and announced that she didn't want to go back to school and she didn't want to talk about the incident.
米勒的篮球赛结束后，阿琳回到了克劳溪的宿舍。但她开始比平时更频繁地给家里打电话。几周后，她回家探望，并宣布她不想回学校了，也不想谈论这件事。
I never told nobody my feelings about it. I tried, but I can't. It can't come out.
我从没告诉任何人我对这件事的感受。我试过，但不行。说不出口。
When she came home, her dad took her out back and taught her to shoot a gun. He thought it might relieve her anger. But it just gave her flashbacks of hiding on the floor of the car. Arlene left the clothes from the Miller night in the laundry basket for three weeks. Eventually she started wearing them again, but not together, the pants with a different shirt and the shirt with different pants.
当她回家时，她爸爸带她到后面教她用枪。他想这也许能减轻她的愤怒。但这只会让她想起在车厢地板上躲避的情景。阿琳把米勒那个晚上的衣服在洗衣篮里放了三周。最终她又开始穿它们，但不是一起穿，裤子配不同的衬衫，衬衫配不同的裤子。
At home, Arlene's mom told her, whenever you're ready, come and talk. But Arlene was silent and she refused to leave the house.
在家里，阿琳的妈妈告诉她：“准备好了随时来谈谈。”但阿琳保持沉默，拒绝出门。
I didn't want to see no white people. I just stayed home. My sister asked me to go to movies. But I didn't go with her because I would see white people. I didn't like white people.
我不想看到任何白人。我只是呆在家里。我姐姐叫我去看电影，我没去，因为我会看到白人。我不喜欢白人。
For two weeks Arlene sat on the couch. Maybe she'd quit school. Maybe she'd quit basketball, which seemed to make white people hate you even more. Then one night, she headed out in the car.
两周时间，阿琳都坐在沙发上。也许她会退学。也许她会放弃篮球，那似乎只会让白人更加讨厌你。然后一天晚上，她开车出去了。
I left and I went and sat on a hill back there. And it's like a big old hill. You can see everything, all the houses. You see everything there. And I just sat up there and I was just thinking how we got treated. And I don't know how white people think they should be the only ones on this earth. I thought I'd make everyone feel better if we weren't here, if I wasn't. But then I thought how my family would suffer. So I didn't. I came home.
我离开了，坐在后面的一座山上。那是一座大山。你可以看到一切，所有的房子。你可以看到那里的一切。我坐在那儿，想着我们受到的待遇。我不知道为什么白人认为他们应该是地球上唯一的人类。我以为如果我们不存在了，如果我不存在了，会让大家感觉更好。但后来我想到了我的家人会遭受多大的痛苦。所以我没那么做。我回家了。
I think it was about 2:30 in the morning.
我想大概是凌晨2:30。
This is Arlene's mom, Lucille.
这是阿琳的妈妈，露西尔。
And I was asleep right here. And she just told me, you know, mom, I'm ready. So I said, let's go. And so we went outside. We stood there and I remember it was really kind of a cold night. And the stars were really bright. And then I just asked her to tell me.
我当时就在这儿睡着了。她告诉我：“你知道，妈，我准备好了。”所以我说：“走吧。”于是我们到了外面。我们站在那儿，我记得那是个非常寒冷的夜晚。星星特别明亮。然后我就让她告诉我。
Arlene and Lucille talked about how she wanted to kill herself, quit school, never wanted to play ball again. And by the morning, Arlene believed that she was stronger than the awful thing that happened. And she was ready to go back to school. Lucille told her she couldn't let that one boy take everything away. She taught her a lesson a lot of Native American mothers teach their children. You can't let racism ruin your life. But it exists. And you have to be practical about it.
阿琳和露西尔谈到了她如何想要自杀、退学、再也不想打球。到了早晨，阿琳相信自己比发生的那些可怕的事情更坚强。她准备好回学校了。露西尔告诉她，不能让那个男孩夺走一切。她教给她很多原住民母亲教给孩子的一课：你不能让种族主义毁了你的生活，但它确实存在，你必须对此保持清醒和务实。
We teach our children, when you go shopping anywhere, just because we're Native American, you do not have anything on you that does not have a receipt.
我们教导孩子，去任何地方购物时，仅仅因为我们是原住民，你的身上绝对不能带着任何没有收据的东西。
Again, Jessica's mother, Jenny.
再次是杰西卡的母亲，珍妮。
I teach my children to always do the best that they can with their abilities. But if there's ever a selection and there's a non-Indian involved, and even though you're the most qualified, chances are you might not get selected just because you're Native. So we build them up and yet you put insecurities in their minds.
我教导孩子们要尽自己所能做得最好。但如果有选择时，并且涉及非印第安人，即使你是最有资格的，你也有可能因为是原住民而不被选中。所以我们在培养他们，却又在他们的脑海中种下了不安全感。
For the Native Americans, this is the context for the shooting. Lucille tells me about a host of racial incidents where there was a comment or a look against her or one of her girls. Some whites in South Dakota believe that Native Americans get everything from the government for free including their houses, which, of course isn't true.
对原住民来说，这就是枪击事件的背景。露西尔告诉了我一连串的种族事件，有些是对她或她女孩的评论或眼神。南达科他州的一些白人相信原住民从政府那里免费得到了一切，包括他们的房子，这当然不是真的。
One time I went into the Family Thrift Center in Rapid City. And we went through line. And I said, can I have dry ice for my meat? And she said, there's a fee for it. So I said, oh, OK. I never knew they charged for dry ice. And she said, well you can't expect everything free. So I said, you know, I was going to pay for it. I never knew I was charged for it.
有一次我去拉皮德城（Rapid City）的家庭廉价中心。我们排队经过。我说：“能给我一点干冰存放我的肉吗？”她说：“这要收费的。”我说：“哦，好的。”我从来不知道干冰要收费。她说：“好吧，你不能指望什么都免费。”我说，你知道，我本来打算付钱的。我只是不知道要收费。
And I kind of looked at my surroundings. And then there was some white people behind me. And I felt really embarrassed. And I started thinking about, you know, I work so hard. I have a job and everything. And I didn't know. And I just went off on her. Are you saying that because I'm Native American because a lot of them do get free things? And I told her that there are some Indians that work. And I'm one of them. I don't appreciate you saying that to me.
我环顾了一下周围。后面有一些白人。我感到非常尴尬。我开始心想，你知道，我工作非常努力。我有份工作什么的。我真的不知道。于是我跟她吵了起来。“你这么说是以为我是原住民，因为他们很多人都能得到免费东西吗？”我告诉她，有些印第安人是在工作的，我也是其中之一。我不喜欢你那样跟我说话。
Coming up, white kids in the town of Miller explained how the Indians have it all wrong about the night of the shooting. In a minute, from Chicago Public Radio and Public Radio International when our program continues.
接下来，米勒镇的白人孩子将解释为什么印第安人对枪击之夜的情况完全理解错了。一分钟后，从芝加哥公共广播电台和国际公共广播电台节目继续。
It's This American Life . I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program, of course, we choose some theme, bring you a variety of different kinds of stories on that theme. Today's program, High Speed Chase. Susan Burton's story about South Dakota continues.
这里是《此美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周我们都会选择一个主题，带来各种不同的故事。今天的节目，《高速追捕》。苏珊·伯顿关于南达科他州的故事继续。
In Miller, it's hard to get the teenagers to talk about the Crow Creek incident. Most of them are sensitive about the way their town has been portrayed. One girl tells me that because of the Internet, people all over the United States probably think Miller is a racist town. And we're not racist, they tell me. The chief of police says that after the story started appearing in the paper, the teenage witnesses he interviewed would just clam up when he got to the race questions, just not say anything at all.
在米勒，很难让青少年谈论克劳溪事件。他们大多对外界塑造他们小镇形象的方式很敏感。一个女孩告诉我，因为互联网，全美的人可能都认为米勒是个种族主义小镇。他们告诉我，我们不是种族主义者。警察局长说，在故事开始出现在报纸上后，他采访的青少年目击者一提到种族问题就闭口不谈，什么都不肯说。
Because the boys are juveniles, their names haven't been published in the press. And they're not talking to reporters. Their lawyers did not return repeated phone calls. The teenagers in Miller are very protective of them. Many won't say the names. But every teenager in Miller knows why that one boy fired a shotgun.
因为男孩们是未成年人，他们的名字没有在媒体上公布。他们也不跟记者说话。他们的律师没有回复反复拨打的电话。米勒的青少年非常维护他们。许多人不会说出名字。但米勒的每个青少年都知道那个男孩为什么要开散弹枪。
I know the reason that he did it is that he was drunk. And that's not an excuse to shoot a gun or anything. But his car is his baby. And they threw a milkshake right at it. As far as I'm concerned, they were asking for something. They were just asking for a good butt whooping. I mean, if you saw a really sexy race car and you threw a milkshake at it, of course you'd be expecting the owner to be a little bit torked.
我知道他这么做的原因是他喝醉了。这并不是开枪的借口，但他的车就像他的孩子。他们往上面扔奶昔。在我看来，他们是自找的。他们就是想找顿揍。我是说，如果你看到一辆超级性感的赛车，然后往上面扔奶昔，当然会预料到车主会有点发火。
The boy was famous for taking care of his car. It's a Buick sports car with a bra on it. And  he paid for it himself. The explanation is related with fervor by all the teenagers. This is honestly how they see it. Even teenagers who are sympathetic to the Crow Creek girls, like Nicole, high school junior.
那个男孩以爱护他的车而闻名。那是一辆前面有保护罩的别克跑车，是他自己付钱买的。这种解释在所有青少年中被热烈地叙述。这就是他们眼中的真相。即使是对克劳溪女孩表示同情的青少年，比如高中三年级的尼可（Nicole）。
I mean, who wouldn't be scared if a gun was being fired? And the only thing that can be crossed into your mind is that oh my god, I might be shot or I might die. I mean, who wouldn't be scared of that? But then again, I mean, they can't put all the blame on us. Because they were the ones that threw the milkshake on the car and set that boy off. Because that boy is very, I don't know, he likes to take care of his car a lot. He doesn't even like water being thrown on it because he's afraid that the water is leave spots on his window. I mean who wouldn't get mad if a milkshake was just being thrown on the car.
我的意思是，如果有枪在开火，谁会不害怕？你脑子里唯一闪过的念头就是：天哪，我可能会被击中或者我会死。我是说，谁会不害怕那个？但话说回来，我的意思是，他们不能把所有的责任都推给我们。因为是他们先往车上扔奶昔，才让那个男孩失控的。那个男孩非常，我不知道，他非常喜欢照顾他的车。他甚至不喜欢水喷在上面，因为他害怕水会留在窗户上留下斑点。我是说，如果车上被扔了奶昔，谁会不生气呢？
In a sense, the disagreement over what happened that night is a dispute over where the story begins. And for the teenagers in Miller, the story begins right there. It starts the moment the smoothie smacks down on the car. The teenagers all tell me how the newspapers and the Native Americans started bringing things into it, the war whoops, the racial remarks. They thought this was adding parts to the story that didn't make sense. They just don't see any connection between the racial remarks and the high speed chase. Most of the Miller teenager don't even believe that their crowd made racial remarks that night.
在某种意义上，对那天晚上发生的争论，是关于故事从何处开始的争议。对于米勒的青少年来说，故事就从那儿开始。它始于奶昔拍在车上的那一刻。青少年们都告诉我，报纸和原住民是如何开始把事情牵扯进来的，战号、种族言论。他们认为这是在给故事强加那些没意义的细节。他们根本看不出种族言论和高速追捕之间有什么联系。大多数米勒的青少年甚至不相信那天晚上他们的群体发表过种族言论。
One of the teenagers who does is Jennifer. She's 16 and was working at Dairy Queen the night of the shooting. If anything, she says, the racial comments went both ways.
其中一个对此承认的青少年是珍妮弗（Jennifer）。她16岁，枪击之夜在乳品皇后打工。她说，如果有的话，种族评论是双向的。
I wasn't there at the basketball game. But I can't say how it was. But I know, actually, one of my friends did get commented on being racist. I mean, not being racist, but having a white racist term yelled at her. And so she yelled one back. And so I think it was like 50/50.
我当时没在篮球赛现场。但我不知道情况是怎样的。但其实我知道，我的一个朋友确实被指责种族歧视。我的意思是，不是种族歧视，而是有人对她吼了一个白人种族主义术语。于是她吼了回去。所以我觉得那是50/50。
She was walking by the stands and she got caught, I think, white trash or something like that. And she was mad and angry. Maybe I don't see the term she used. I actually never heard of it until she was telling the story. I'm like, oh.
她走过看台时，被骂了“白人垃圾”之类的词。她非常愤怒。也许我没看到她用的那个词。直到她讲这个故事之前，我甚至从未听说过它。我当时想：“噢。”
What term is it?
是什么词？
It was prairie nigger.
是“草原黑鬼”。
I don't think she feels bad because she got called it first. And if that person doesn't really feel bad then why should she?
我不觉得她感觉很糟糕，因为是对方先骂她的。如果那个人并不觉得糟糕，她为什么要觉得糟糕？
When the reservation teams come down here, there's a lot of tension.
当保留地的球队来这里时，气氛会很紧张。
This is Candace. She's 16 and wore a coat with a faux fur collar. She's the only teenager I talked to who wore thrift store type clothes, like kids in the city wear.
这是坎迪斯（Candace）。她16岁，穿着一件带人造毛领的外套。她是我采访的唯一一个穿二手店风格衣服的青少年，就像城里的孩子穿的那样。
We've had to have kids get kicked out because of saying Indian, or prairie nigger, and stuff like that. They were raised with it. Their parents taught them. I don't think that you have to say, well, Indians are evil. Don't go near them. They're just taking their money. That's the big thing around here. That's another comment that was made at games that had Indians there. They'd say, oh, you shouldn't even be playing on our damn court because we're paying for your shoes or we're paying for your uniforms.
我们这儿曾经有孩子因为说“印第安人”或“草原黑鬼”之类的词而被开除。他们从小受这种教育。他们的父母教他们的。我不认为你非得说：“嗯，印第安人是邪恶的。别靠近他们。他们只是在骗取钱财。”那是这里的大事。那是比赛现场有印第安人时会做的另一个评论。他们会说：“噢，你们根本不该在我们的球场上打球，因为我们付了你们的鞋钱，或是我们付了你们的队服钱。”
Candace has lived in Miller for three years now. But before this, she lived in a lot of other places. Her family moved 20 times before she was five, she says. It was because of her dad. He wasn't in the Army. He was in the New Age Movement.
坎迪斯来米勒已经三年了。但在这之前，她住过很多别的地方。她说她五岁前搬家了20次。是因为她爸爸。他不在军队，他在搞“新时代运动”。
He believes he was an alien from outer space come to save humans, us, from the bad aliens who were in cahoots with the government, selling dead bodies for more technology. And he was building spaceships in our garage and going on spaceship meetings and spaceship trips with his friends. And we moved around a lot because I think we were running from the law. I think the most I remember about him was watching Star Trek with him and eating popcorn. That's all I remember.
他相信自己是来自外星的外星人，来拯救人类，我们，免受与政府勾结、出卖尸体获取更多技术的邪恶外星人的伤害。他在车库里制造宇宙飞船，和朋友去参加宇宙飞船会议和宇宙飞船旅行。我们经常搬家，因为我觉得我们是在逃避法律。我对他印象最深的是和他一起看《星际迷航》，吃爆米花。我只记得这些。
Candace likes Miller. She says there are good people here. Not everyone says bad stuff a basketball games. Candace sees the tensions that do come up as part of an ongoing history.
坎迪斯喜欢米勒。她说这里有好人。并不是每个人在篮球赛上都说坏话。坎迪斯认为出现紧张气氛是长期历史的一部分。
It's the whole cowboys versus Indians thing, you know? I mean Custer and all that other crap that happened, Wounded Knee. That stuff is hardcore. Cowboys, I mean, I'm talking the works. When they work, they put on those chaps and everything. They go cattle driving. They brand. It's cowboy, cowboy, cowboy. I mean, everybody. The kids too, in school, cowboy boots, big old huge belt buckles that take up half their stomach.
这就是所谓的“牛仔大战印第安人”，你知道吗？我是指卡斯特（Custer）和所有其他的那些烂事，伤膝河大屠杀。那是硬核的历史。牛仔，我的意思是，我是说真的。当他们工作时，他们穿上皮裤之类的。他们去放牧，去烙印。这全是牛仔，牛仔，牛仔。我是指所有人。学生们也是，穿牛仔靴，系着占了大半个胃部的大腰带扣。
The cowboys in my town, they do not like Indians. They will let you know it. And they don't like black people. They like white people. They even have a problem with me sometimes because I'm a little eccentric for the people around here. I wear weird clothes from the city. And even that will freak them out. It's all about tradition. If you're not the traditional, they don't like it at all.
我镇上的牛仔们，他们不喜欢印第安人。他们会让你知道的。他们也不喜欢黑人。他们喜欢白人。他们有时甚至对我有意见，因为我对周围的人来说有点古怪。我穿城里的怪衣服。即使那样也会让他们感到不安。这全是关于传统。如果你不传统，他们根本就不喜欢你。
If there's a frontier mentality at some South Dakota schools, frontier country is looking more and more like it used to. Native prairie grass is growing over abandoned farmland. There are more buffalo on the planes than anytime since the 1870s. And the population is shrinking, enough so that the region meets the 19th century census bureau definition of frontier, six people or fewer per square mile.
如果一些南达科他州的学校有边疆心态，那边疆地区看起来越来越像过去的样子了。本地草原草长在废弃的农田上。平原上的水牛比1870年代以来的任何时候都多。人口正在缩减，缩减到该地区符合19世纪人口普查局对边疆的定义，即每平方英里六人或更少。
South Dakota, like a lot of this region, is on the white side, getting older.
南达科他州，像该地区的许多地方一样，白人这一侧正在老龄化。
Jennifer Ring is the only ACLU staffer for two states, North Dakota and South Dakota.
珍妮弗·林（Jennifer Ring）是两个州——北达科他州和南达科他州的唯一一名美国公民自由联盟（ACLU）工作人员。
The folks are leaving the farm. So you have an aging white population and a thinning white population. At the same time, the Native American population it is very young. They have a higher birth rate. And their kids tend much more to stay in the state. And that means that as time goes on, power really is shifting.
人们正在离开农场。所以你有一个正在老龄化的白人人口和一个正在减少的白人人口。与此同时，美洲原住民人口非常年轻。他们有更高的出生率。而且他们的孩子更有可能留在州内。这意味着随着时间推移，权力确实在转移。
The 2000 census showed some rural counties losing 10% to 20% of their population in a decade while the number of Native Americans in the state grew 23%. It's hard to say exactly what that means since Native Americans have probably been severely undercounted in previous years.
2000年的人口普查显示，一些农村县在十年内损失了10%到20%的人口，而州内的美洲原住民人数增长了23%。很难说这到底意味着什么，因为美洲原住民在往年可能被严重低估了。
But the changing demographics are dramatic in some communities right near the reservations, border towns. Some of the ACLU's current voting rights cases involve efforts by whites to block the new influence of Native Americans in local elections, like for school boards. But some of the biggest complaints are with the criminal justice system.
但在保留地附近的一些社区——边境城镇，人口结构的变化是巨大的。一些美国公民自由联盟目前的投票权案件涉及白人试图阻止美洲原住民在地方选举（如学校董事会选举）中产生新影响力。但最大的投诉之一来自刑事司法系统。
In the past few years, there have been a handful of deaths the Native community feels haven't been taken seriously by law enforcement. They feel that racial profiling is rampant, that they're punished more harshly than whites. The U.S. Civil Rights Commission looked into all this a couple years ago. They invited Native Americans and others to come to a Holiday Inn and tell their stories. Dozens showed up.
在过去几年中，发生了少数几起原住民社区认为执法部门没有认真对待的死亡事件。他们觉得种族定性非常猖獗，他们受到的惩罚比白人更严厉。美国民权委员会几年前调查了所有这一切。他们邀请美洲原住民和其他人来到假日酒店讲述他们的故事。几十个人出现了。
Not everybody could speak at the hearing. They had people taking testimony off to the side from all these people. And the committee report was absolutely scathing about Native Americans and the South Dakota justice system. The chairman of the U.S. Civil Rights Commission said that this was worse than anything she was seeing in LA or any of those places. There was clear, pervasive, overwhelming lack of faith in the justice department by the community. And that needed to be addressed. Unfortunately, rather than trying to address that seriously, the governor of South Dakota dismissed it.
并不是每个人都能在听证会上发言。他们安排人在侧面听取所有这些人的证词。委员会的报告对美洲原住民和南达科他州的司法系统进行了极其严厉的批评。美国民权委员会主席说，这比她在洛杉矶或任何其他地方看到的任何事情都要糟糕。原住民社区对司法部门明显存在普遍且压倒性的不信任，而这需要得到解决。遗憾的是，南达科他州州长不仅没有试图认真解决，反而否认了这一点。
Governor William Janklow claimed the hearings weren't a true portrait and commissioned his own study to figure out exactly what was going on. Its release has been delayed.
州长威廉·扬克洛（William Janklow）声称听证会并没有描绘出真实情况，并委托他自己的研究来弄清楚到底发生了什么。该研究的发布已被推迟。
The problem seems even worse when you consider the fact that according to a 1999 Justice Department study, American Indians are more likely to be the victims of interracial violence than any other race. And more than 60% of the time, the aggressor is a white person. In comparison, blacks are victimized by whites about 12% of the time.
考虑到根据1999年司法部的一项研究，美国印第安人比任何其他种族更有可能成为种族间暴力受害者的事实，问题似乎更加严重。超过60%的情况下，施暴者是白人。相比之下，黑人被白人伤害的概率约为12%。
It would be hard to find anybody in this community that was sympathetic to what they did.
在这个社区很难找到任何对他们所作所为表示同情的人。
Sheriff Doug DeBoer from Miller.
警长道格·德波尔（Doug DeBoer），来自米勒。
At least I haven't seen any. They were all either quite embarrassed or quite angry about what happened.
至少我没见到一个。他们要么感到非常尴尬，要么对发生的事情感到非常愤怒。
When it came time for the Miller boys to be punished, the people of Miller wanted Crow Creek to know that they took the crime seriously. The State's Attorney, Jim Jones, charged the boys with aggravated assault and petitioned to transfer them to adult court where they could face up to 90 years in prison. But he and the police did not see the crime as part of a larger pattern of interracial violence. Chief of Police, Ernie Stirling ran the investigation.
当米勒男孩需要受到惩罚时，米勒的人们想让克劳溪知道他们认真对待这项犯罪。州检察官吉姆·琼斯指控男孩们犯有严重攻击罪，并申请将他们移交至成人法庭审理，在那里他们可能面临最高90年的监禁。但他和警察并不认为该犯罪是种族间暴力更大模式的一部分。警察局长厄尼·斯特林（Ernie Stirling）负责调查。
Maybe for the Native American population similar things have happened elsewhere enough that they feel justified in saying this is the trend. This is the way we get treated when we go somewhere else. Maybe that's the case. I personally don't have any knowledge of that. All I can speak about is here, in Miller, South Dakota where I've worked since 1979, this has never happened before.
也许对原住民群体而言，类似的事情在别的地方发生得够多了，以至于他们觉得有正当理由说这是一个趋势。这是我们去其他地方时受到的待遇。也许是这样。我个人并不了解。我只能说，在米勒，南达科他州，我从1979年就在这工作，这种事以前从未发生过。
In the end, the police investigation couldn't prove that the two boys in the car were the ones who made racial remarks back on the side of the road or at the game. So like most of the town, State's Attorney Jim Jones concluded that this was not a racially motivated incident.
最终，警察调查无法证明车里的两个男孩是路边或比赛现场发表种族言论的人。所以像镇上大多数人一样，州检察官吉姆·琼斯得出结论，这不是一起种族动机事件。
I think to the extent that there was anything racially offensive offered by either of those kids at any juncture that night, and I underline the word if, I'm very sorry that that happened. But I think uttering a racially offensive epithets would have been evidence of dumb decision making. I think chasing those girls at high speeds and discharging a weapon out the window was evidence of bad decision making. I don't think the two are related anymore than they are evidence that the decision makers have made a series of bad decisions.
我认为，如果那天晚上那两个孩子在任何时候提供了任何种族冒犯性的言论——我加粗“如果”这个词——我感到非常遗憾。但我认为说出种族冒犯性称呼本身是愚蠢决策的证据。我认为高速追赶女孩并从窗户向外开火是糟糕决策的证据。我不认为两者有关联，正如我不认为它们证明了决策者做出了一系列糟糕的决定。
The judge declined to try the boys as adults, which is what happens under South Dakota law if a teenager seems like he can be rehabilitated in the juvenile system. But for Jessica and Arlene, this decision just seemed to confirm that the crime wasn't being taken seriously. Here's Arlene.
法官拒绝将男孩们作为成人审判，这是根据南达科他州法律，如果青少年看起来可以在少年系统中改造，就会出现这种情况。但对杰西卡和阿琳来说，这个决定似乎只是确认了犯罪没有被认真对待。这是阿琳。
Like so many times they delayed it. I really didn't care of it. They aren't going to get anything done. They didn't care. I thought they were like, oh the Indians, just forget about it. I thought they were thinking that.
就像他们拖延了那么多次一样。我真的不在乎了。他们什么都不会做。他们根本不在乎。我心想他们是在想：“噢，那是印第安人，算了吧。”我想他们就是那么想的。
Hearing that the legal system didn't consider this a racially motivated incident just made things worse. Now Jessica figured that the boys would just get probation. She no longer had any confidence that the court system was going to handle things right. She even felt like her own high school was trying to pretend that what happened wasn't so bad. At one point Jessica, the homecoming queen, almost walked out of a boy's basketball game in which Crow Creek and Wessington Springs attempted to make peace.
听说司法系统没把这件事视为种族动机事件，让情况变得更糟了。现在杰西卡认为男孩们只会得到缓刑。她再也不相信法院系统能把事情处理好。她甚至觉得她自己的高中都在试图假装发生的事情没那么严重。有一次杰西卡，那个返校节女王，差点走出一场男生篮球赛，那是克劳溪和威辛顿温泉试图言归于好的一场比赛。
Before the boys actually played, they called each student councils onto the floor. And they made truce that hopefully everything will be resolved. And I was just sitting up there in the crowd. I was like, this has been happening to you guys for how many years and you guys are just going to call a truce and everything go? It's always going to be there. There's nothing you guys can say or do to say it's going to be OK. It's always going to be there.
在男孩们真正比赛之前，他们把每个学生会都叫到了球场上。他们达成休战协议，希望一切能得到解决。我只是坐在人群中。我想：“这种事在你们身上已经发生多少年了，你们现在只是要达成一个休战，然后一切就过去了？”它永远在那儿。你们没有任何话可以说或做来让事情变得“没事”。它永远都在那儿。
The Hand County Courthouse is the grandest building in Miller. Inside, there are marble columns and a stained glass dome. As you climb the stairs, it's like you're entering another time when people were making up the rules of the country.
汉德县法院是米勒最宏伟的建筑。里面有大理石柱和彩色玻璃穹顶。当你爬上楼梯时，就像走进了一个人们正在制定国家规则的旧时代。
On the morning of the boys hearing, every single person in the courtroom is white. There are other cases first, mostly drinking offenses. A 19-year-old in Levi's refuses to say where he got the beer and gets ten days in jail. The court reporter blows her bangs off her face. Jim Jones rises to respond to the judge's queries.
男孩们听证会的那天早上，法庭上的每一个人都是白人。先是处理其他案件，大多是饮酒违规。一个穿牛仔裤的19岁少年拒绝透露啤酒是从哪儿弄到的，被判入狱十天。法庭记录员吹了吹额前的刘海。吉姆·琼斯站起来回应法官的询问。
And then suddenly the sheriff pushes open the door and Jessica, and Arlene, and their mothers, and several others walk into the room. The attention shifts. People edge around trying to see what the Native Americans in the courtroom are doing here. And then it just starts into motion, a regular case on the list. This will not be a trial. The boys have entered a guilty plea and the judge will just give them their sentences. A boy with spiky hair appears and the proceedings begin.
接着，警长突然推开门，杰西卡、阿琳、她们的母亲和其他几个人走进了房间。注意力转移了。人们挪动着身体，试图看这些原住民在法庭上要做什么。然后它就开始启动了，就像名单上的一个普通案件。这不会是一场审判。男孩们已经认罪，法官只会宣布判决。一个长着尖刺发型的男孩出现，程序开始了。
His lawyers spends a lot of time talking about the car. The boy is very protective of it and has been upset when it's been paintballed in the past. The lawyer says that the boy has never been in trouble before. The boy stands and mumbles, I would just like to tell the court and everybody involved in this incident that I'm really sorry and I regret it every day of my life. That's it.
他的律师花了很多时间谈论那辆车。男孩非常爱护它，过去被喷彩弹时非常心烦。律师说男孩以前从没惹过麻烦。男孩站起来喃喃自语：“我只想告诉法庭和参与此事件的所有人，我真的很抱歉，我每天都为此感到后悔。”就是这样。
Then Judge Jon Erickson begins. In every lie, there's an element of truth, he says. The truth is you went around the girls. But it wasn't to avoid smashing into them as you said in your statement, but rather to cut them off. The truth is you went to the police station. But the impression that you're trying to give here today, that you were going to be truthful about this, is not true. I don't see any remorse. I don't see that you're a bit contrite.
然后法官乔恩·埃里克森（Jon Erickson）开始了陈述。他说，每一个谎言中都有一点真相。真相是你确实绕过了女孩们。但正如你在声明中所说，这并不是为了避免撞上她们，而是为了别住她们。真相是你确实去了警察局。但你今天试图留下的印象，即你会对此实话实说，那是不真实的。我没看到任何悔意。我没看到你有丝毫忏悔。
Judge Erickson named more parts of the boy's story he doesn't believe. He chastises him for his behavior. And he continues, if I read the news reports correctly, there are some who say the only way to be fair in this case, the only way to do justice, is to punish you harshly. If I thought for one moment that by treating you harshly I could cure racism in the state, I would probably do so. If I thought for one moment that could cure the years of distrust between Indians and whites in this country, I would do so. But fortunately for you, I can't do that. Instead, I'm required to make a reasoned judgment.
埃里克森法官列举了更多他不相信的男孩故事中的部分。他因男孩的行为谴责他。他继续说，如果我没看错新闻报道，有些人说在这个案件中公平的唯一方式，伸张正义的唯一方式，就是严厉惩罚你。如果我有一刻认为通过严厉对待你就能治愈该州的种族主义，我可能会那样做。如果我有一刻认为这能治愈这个国家印第安人与白人之间多年的不信任，我会这样做。但幸运的是，对你来说，我做不到。相反，我被要求做出合理的判断。
In South Dakota, a judge can either give juveniles probation or send them to juvenile detention. The judge chose the more severe option for both boys, the Department of Corrections.
在南达科他州，法官可以给予青少年缓刑或将他们送往少年拘留所。法官为两个男孩选择了更严厉的选项——惩教部门。
Just before the proceedings ended, Jim Jones announced that there were victims and the families present and asked if any of them would like to approach the bench.
程序结束前，吉姆·琼斯宣布受害者和家属在场，并询问是否有人想走到审判席前。
I raised my hand and I'm like, do I stay here? Do I sit here and talk or what do I do?
我举起手心想：“我待在这儿吗？我坐在那儿说话还是我该怎么办？”
Here's Arlene's mother, Lucille.
这是阿琳的妈妈，露西尔。
I didn't want to do something wrong where the judge might make a comment to me or anything. Then he just told me to approach the bench. You mean go up there? But I sat down. And I looked and I saw all the people in the courtroom. I looked at Arlene and then I thought, OK. Well, I'm going to have to bring everybody up. And then that's what I did.
我不想做错什么导致法官对我发表评论之类的。然后他只是告诉我走近审判席。你的意思是走到那儿去？但我坐下了。我看了看，看到了法庭上的所有人。我看了看阿琳，然后心想：好吧。嗯，我得把大家都叫上去。然后我就是这么做的。
Lucille sat in the witness chair swiveling a little from side to side. She focused on one of the boys who'd been in juvenile corrections before. She told him that she didn't feel sorry for him, that she didn't think that he felt sorry for the girls. She said that he'd had all these chances to better himself, to improve. She said, he should have been obedient to his parents. Lucille looked at the boy's mother.
露西尔坐在证人席上，左右摇晃着。她专注于其中一个曾经进过少年惩教所的男孩。她告诉他，她对他并不感到抱歉，她不认为他为女孩们感到抱歉。她说他曾经拥有所有那些改善自己、提升自己的机会。她说他应该服从父母。露西尔看着那个男孩的母亲。
She kind of had her head down. But she was looking at me on the side of her eye. In our culture we have minimum eye contact. If we stare or tend to look at someone for a period of time, then it becomes disrespectful. And I know that like in the white man's world, eye contact is important. It shows interest. And that day I went in there on his terms. So I was going to stare. Because I don't have respect for them anyway.
她有点低着头。但她从眼角余光看着我。在我们的文化中，我们尽量减少眼神接触。如果我们盯着看或倾向于长时间注视某人，那就会变得不尊重。我知道像在白人的世界里，眼神接触很重要。它显示兴趣。那天，我是在他的规则下进去的。所以我打算盯着看。因为我无论如何都不尊重他们。
She was just brutally honest.
她当时非常诚实，毫不留情。
Again, the State's Attorney, Jim Jones.
再次是州检察官，吉姆·琼斯。
She turned to these kids and she says, look what kind of an impact you have had on the lives of these six girls. How can you look at yourself in the mirror and think that you have not wreaked havoc with these girls' personal lives. If you find yourself in a cell, I want you to spend some time thinking about the impact your idiotic decision that night has had on the lives of others.
她转向这些孩子说：“看看你们对这六个女孩的生活造成了多大的影响。你们怎么能对着镜子审视自己，认为你们没有对这些女孩的个人生活造成浩劫。如果发现自己被关在牢房里，我希望你们花点时间思考一下你们那个夜晚愚蠢的决定对他人生活的影响。”
I kind of thought about all the things that happened, even to me, the racism and how we're mistreated. And sometimes the justice system or the non-Indians tend to say, oh, they exaggerate. But it's not exaggerated.
我回想了所有发生的事情，甚至是发生在我身上的，种族主义，我们是如何受到虐待的。有时司法系统或非印第安人倾向于说：“噢，她们夸大其词。”但那不是夸大。
Arlene was crying when her mother spoke.
当她母亲说话时，阿琳在哭。
I didn't think she was going to go off like that. I was pretty happy because my mom was the only one that got up and talked. It made me feel cool that she really cares.
我没想到她会讲出那番话。我挺高兴的，因为我妈是唯一一个站起来说话的人。我感觉挺酷的，因为她真的很在乎。
The girls in the families felt like the hearing was a success, that this time the justice system took a crime as seriously as they did. They liked the things the judge said when he scolded the boys. And they were glad that the people in the room heard the Indian point of view from Lucille. They told me about so many cases where things never seemed to get resolved fairly and bad feelings lingered. But this was settled. They could put it behind them.
女孩们和家属们觉得听证会很成功，这一次司法系统像她们一样认真对待了一起犯罪。她们喜欢法官斥责男孩时说的话。她们很高兴房间里的人听到了露西尔带来的印第安视角。她们告诉我太多案件，事情似乎永远无法公平解决，坏情绪挥之不去。但这件事解决了。她们可以把它抛在脑后了。
After the hearing, Lucille hugged her daughters.
听证会后，露西尔拥抱了她的女儿们。
They're descendants of Sitting Bull. And Sitting Bull was really a great chief. And one of the things I always keep in mind from some of the things that he said, I can't really recall the whole thing, but he talks about how if the white man leaves something good, pick it and use it. And if he leaves something bad, then leave it where it is. So I kind of like that. I kind of liked that little statement that Sitting Bull made. And I think I left that bad thing in the courtroom.
她们是坐牛（Sitting Bull）的后代。坐牛曾经是一位非常伟大的酋长。他说过的一件我一直记在心里的事——我不记得全部了，但他谈到，如果白人留下了好东西，就拿来用；如果他留下了坏东西，就让它留在原地。所以我挺喜欢那样的。我挺喜欢坐牛说的那个小陈述。我想我把那个坏东西留在法庭上了。
The people on the reservation and the people in Miller never came to agree on where the story began. But for Lucille and her daughters, here's where it ended: They got in their car and drove to Crow Creek. They went to the casino, and ate cheese balls, and folded Arlene's graduation announcements. The girls joked with the waiter. They didn't even talk about court.
保留地上的人和米勒的人永远没能就故事从哪儿开始达成一致。但对露西尔和她的女儿们来说，故事结束于此：她们上了车，开车回了克劳溪。她们去了赌场，吃了奶酪球，折叠了阿琳的毕业通知书。女孩们跟服务员开玩笑。她们甚至没谈论法庭的事。
Susan Burton lives in New York.
苏珊·伯顿住在纽约。
Well, our program was produced today by Jonathan Goldstein and myself with Alex Blumberg, Wendy Dorr, and Starlee Kine, senior producer Julie Snyder, contributing editor Susan Burton, Rebecca [? Carroll ?], Jack [? Hitt, ?] Margie [UNINTELLIGIBLE], Alix Spiegel, Nancy Updike, and Consigliere Sarah Vowell. Elizabeth Meister runs our website. Production help from Todd Bachmann and Chris [UNINTELLIGIBLE]. Susan Burton's story was produced with funding from the Corporation for Public Broadcasting.
嗯，我们的节目今天由乔纳森·戈尔茨坦（Jonathan Goldstein）和我自己制作，亚历克斯·布隆伯格（Alex Blumberg）、温迪·多尔（Wendy Dorr）和斯塔莉·凯恩（Starlee Kine）参与。资深制作人朱莉·斯奈德（Julie Snyder），特约编辑苏珊·伯顿，丽贝卡·卡罗尔（Rebecca Carroll），杰克·希特（Jack Hitt），玛吉，阿利克斯·斯皮格尔（Alix Spiegel），南希·厄普代克（Nancy Updike）和顾问莎拉·沃威尔（Sarah Vowell）。伊丽莎白·迈斯特（Elizabeth Meister）管理我们的网站。制作助理托德·巴赫曼（Todd Bachmann）和克里斯。苏珊·伯顿的故事制作获得了公共广播公司（CPB）的资助。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
（鸣谢）
To buy a cassette of this program, call us here at WBEZ Chicago, 312-832-3380 or visit our website where you can also listen to our programs for free, www.thisamericanlife.org. This American Life comes to you from the city of Chicago. Richard M. Daley, mayor. This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International.
要购买本节目的磁带，请致电芝加哥WBEZ，号码312-832-3380，或访问我们的网站，在那里你也可以免费收听我们的节目，www.thisamericanlife.org。本节目来自芝加哥市。理查德·M·戴利，市长。《此美国生活》由国际公共广播电台（PRI）分发。
[FUNDING CREDITS]
（资助鸣谢）
WBEZ management oversight between Torey Malatia, who wants you to be absolutely clear about his location at all times.
WBEZ管理监督托瑞·马拉蒂亚（Torey Malatia），他希望你时刻清楚他的位置。
157, 157, 159. We are approaching 157.
157，157，159。我们正在接近157。
Sir, sir, sir.
先生，先生，先生。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life .
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带回更多《此美国生活》的故事。
PRI Public Radio International.
PRI 国际公共广播电台。